was ist los bei training ist mir
zugeschaltet ist jetzt tennis sprecher
doktor andri viel städte kontakte viele
städte wir wollen gleich zum punkt
kommen wie ist der aktuelle stand wie
sind die zahlen kein neuer alarm das ist
die entscheidende botschaft von den wir
haben 7300 tests in den vergangenen
sieben tagen durchgeführt dafür sind
jetzt 30 positive dabei wir wissen stand
jetzt das definitiv 24 davon alle fälle
sind das heißt mitarbeiter die in den
reihen testung in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten bereits positiv getestet
wurden
ihre quarantäne begangen haben und jetzt
natürlich immer noch das virus in sich
tragen aber nicht mehr infektiös sind
bei sechs weiteren fällen von den
momentan der abgleich mit den behörden
statt ob dieses auch altfälle sind oder
ob das neue sind ganz konkret die frage
haben infizierte gearbeitet
das testsystem ist ja so dass die
mitarbeiter bei uns ankommen vor
arbeitsbeginn getestet werden dann in
den betrieb gehen das testergebnis liegt
ungefähr nach 24 stunden vor
deswegen kann es sein dass ein
mitarbeiter innerhalb des ersten
arbeitstages gearbeitet hat und auch
infektiös war in diesen konkreten fällen
war das aber nicht so entscheidend sind
dann aber die unterschiedlichen säulen
des hygiene konzeptes erstens testen
zweitens abstand und masken und drittens
luftfilterung anlagen wenn alle drei
maßnahmen ineinander greifen und das tut
das gegebene konzept dann ist das risiko
einer weiteren ansteckung sehr gering
warum wartet man nicht 24 stunden auf
das ergebnis und schickt dann die arbeit
erst dann wieder in den betrieb
das ist das konzept so wie es mit den
behörden mit dem gesundheitsamt und auch
in abstimmung mit der beratung des
robert-koch-institutes so abgestimmt und
genehmigt worden ist
dementsprechend weil hier die maßnahmen
ineinander greifen und dadurch das
höchste maß an sicherheit erreicht wird
das haben die behörden genehmigt und
dementsprechend halten wir uns darin der
vier städte welche maßnahmen werden denn
ansonsten noch ergriffen um den
arbeitern intern jetzt bei trainings im
betrieb die größte sicherheit
zu bieten das testen ist die erste hürde
die erste eingangs führte das zweite ist
dann natürlich abstand und masken in
allen bereichen müssen masken
medizinische mundschutzmasken getragen
werden das dritte sind abstände das
heißt mindestens ein meter fünfzig
abstand wo das nicht möglich ist
plexiglasscheiben stellwände sodass
abstände gehalten werden
das kantinen konzept wurde extrem
erweitert es gibt deutlich mehr kantinen
flächen auch abstandsregelung plexiglas
trennung in der kantine all das
maßnahmen die sozusagen dann auch darauf
ein zahlen dass die lüftungsanlagen
deutlich erweitert wurden hier gibt es
ja auch die studie die gestern
veröffentlicht wurde dass das der kern
ursache des ausbruchs ist wir haben
diverse hepa filter high efficiency
filter installiert zusätzliche
uv-bestrahlung anlagen der luft als das
maßnahmen das wenn das virus in den
betrieb käme oder kommt dass es dann
sich nicht so weit ausbreiten kann wie
wir das in der im vergangenen monat
erlebt habe
was hat sich denn bei der unterbringung
der arbeiter- getan
also erstens muss man sagen und das ist
auch ergebnis der wissenschaftliche
studie dass die unterbringung nicht die
ursache für die ausbringung für die
ausbreitung waren trotzdem haben wir
sehr klar gesagt dass wir das thema
anpacken und das thema wohnraum nach
vorne treiben wollen wir wissen da 70
prozent unserer mitarbeiter in privaten
unterkünften wohnen privat auf dem
wohnungsmarkt angemietet 30 prozent
wohnen in gemeinschaftsunterkünften die
uns vom arbeitgeber von unseren
dienstleistern gestellt werden hier sind
wir massiv dabei wohnraum zu schaffen
die ersten 400 zusätzlichen wohnplätze
haben wir bereits akquiriert und wir
unsere bagger stehen jetzt bereit dass
wir auch wir wollen bauen wir sind in
gesprächen mit den kommunen jetzt hier
auch unsere wohnraum konzepte auf
ausland zu bringen
vier städte letzte frage was ist mit den
leiharbeitern wenn die jetzt alle fest
angestellt bei turniers wir sind eher im
ersten pilot das in den kernbereichen
schlachtung zerlegung verpackt
die ersten 1.000 mitarbeiter bis
september eingestellt werden so wie es
auch der gesetzgeber von uns ab dem 1
erst fordert bis zum ersten januar
werden wir das in diesen kernbereichen
machen
das ist aber eine mammutaufgabe wir sind
da ist voll dabei die bei den ersten ist
es schon geschehen und ab dem ersten
september ab dem ersten januar werden
wir das in allen kernbereichen
umgestellt haben dann ihr sprecher dr
andré viele städte vielen herzlichen
dank für dieses gespräch